hey Jackie hey Kevin what are we doing
today today we're spinning a wheel then
we're gonna draw what's on the wheel
great that I get something that I really
really like okay I got to spin first
what anime episode baby I don't know
anything about Salem Moon she transforms
and fights crime okay which minion are
you choosing Jason I'm choosing to draw
the one with the one eye are you excited
to draw Sailor Moon can I be honest with
you I'm very nervous because the
internet loves their anime and if you
screw anything up when it comes to anime
they will let you know so you got sonic
which is a hot button issue right now
very hot button issue I went to watch
the movie because it feels like a
embodiment of a cart crash in slow
motion should I draw a he-man with his
like pink vest or him with his shirt off
when he's like got all the power
his shirts gotta be off man yeah and
they just the iconic he-man look so I
don't draw on an anime style at all I
can't do it
know so I'm not even gonna try okay I'm
going to draw a Americanized version of
Sailor Moon that's a good plan I think
people have done that before right so
I'm not alone you're not alone
you also people love their Sailor Moon
yes Oh people love their Sailor Moon and
if you mess up even once it's gonna
really ruin everything
everyone's gonna notice when you've
watched the trailer for the first time
it was her initial reaction okay so
there's a lot of things about the design
that I feel like could look more
appealing if it looked less realistic
yeah like the lips were a little
off-putting feeling good about Naruto I
grew up reading Naruto I love that guy
I'm gonna be drawing og Naruto young guy
cuz he grows up during the course of the
series right yeah I'm gonna draw the
minions the way I think a deformed
creature made by a super villain civ
look I'm gonna draw a very buff the
buffest he-man the world has ever seen
relatively close to the original cuz I
do naturally draw stuff pretty cartoony
but uh yeah I think I'll add you know
make his eyes a little bigger make him a
little cuter
so the real minion just looks like a
till it pill with an eye wearing like
trousers so I'm gonna do a monstrosity
version of that Naruto is constructed
like a real boy you know he's not
cartoony well obviously like it's like
cartoon it's anime I'm gonna go for a
more exaggerated he-man look his
original construction no man if you go
to like a life drawing class and just
give the dude some like blonde friar boy
hair it's kind of what you get with he
meant here's what I know about Sailor
Moon she changes into Sailor Moon kind
of like how Diana Prince changes into
Wonder Woman right they like spin around
and there's like magic
and then she was gonna say to me and I
know that she's part of like a girl
force yes of like five or six other
fighters are they all also nautical
based nautical based yeah this is sailor
oh she's not actually a sailor no
Internet I'm so sorry
Luffy is very lanky really a real tall
guy but he's got like a nice kind of
elasticity to him cuz he's a he's a
comical character you know I think I
really want to keep that intact might
just add a little bit of geometry to
like his back and his body and stuff
here's a little tip for you kids oh if
you are drawing a face and you want to
know if your proportions are correct I
highly recommend taking your drawing and
flipping it horizontally as I just did
and now I can see that boy her eye is
wrong place so do you think you're gonna
go you're gonna want to sonic the Ruby
though we'll see
honestly I'm interested to see how they
alter it because they are gonna change
his characters I'm friend did you watch
he-man growing up absolutely not I don't
think they were even doing like reruns
in the 90s / mm minor ho is definitely a
fan art Naruto I'm just drawing him as I
would draw anybody else in my style oh
he is like Conan the Barbarian boots
he's basically Conan the Barbarian for
kids oh yeah I guess so I guess that's
their being inspired by that stuff yeah
inspired with quotes I think one of my
favorite parts of Sailor Moon is that
it's got lots of fun expressions oh yeah
yeah I don't know if you've seen any of
them ever but it's not that it goes off
model but you know how an anime they
often do like oh right like when they
get really excited they suddenly turn
into G B yeah I think Sailor Moon does
it best
I don't know if this even has the
essence of Sonic it's it's Sonic
adjacent okay so I just noticed that she
has a forehead band that I did not put
in my drawing and so the internet would
be very upset if I didn't so I got a
almost died so this is the best part
about he-man the way I am most familiar
with him is that 4 Non Blondes meme
Jason do you know what I'm talking about
I don't remember that I don't know the
name do you know oh no I do when they're
dancing in the pin the bar yeah yeah
yeah yeah and they like cut together
just like a couple of frames of he-man
like doing like a little twist and it
looks like he's dancing that's about as
good as the internet guy all right home
stretch Jackie how you feeling feeling
good feeling ready are you ready I'm
getting close I think this is the best I
can do you know I'm done this is Sonic
I'm so excited to see you dun dun dun I
think my minions done all right I do not
know what I was thinking with the po is
in this one it's weird I think my
drawings are really reminiscent of what
I grew up drawing do a lot of spider-man
and like when I think of characters they
all have like gangly moving limbs I
think I did do it I think he looks cool
I took a different approach
and sort of emphasize the muscular
aspect of the character I think I am
very successful at making people upset
I'm sorry everybody I think I did okay
it is not anime at all nothing wrong
with that nothing wrong it's fan art and
for what it is I think I'm pretty proud
of it you know what that's all that
matters
oh my god Jason I think the minion
brought out some of the best in you oh
so it's so joyful yeah yeah all right it
really isn't anime but it really is
Kevin's Drive thank you I like it thank
you
if Sailor Moon was on ice in New York
this is the girl that would play her
what cure did is to make him much more
fun and bouncy you can almost see what
dance he's gonna do next
he-man is so ridiculous I love that his
drawing embraces that like he looks
impossibly muscular you made him a lot
cuter there's a lot more appeal to him
you know his original character is very
it's very realistic
I feel like this Naruto has a lot more
fun the reference image you have right
now that's an angry nerd is he angry
most of the time no he's very goofy Oh
Naruto's a goofy guy okay I think you
really captured the essence of how
radical he is the hair got it its iconic
we did some creepy science experiments
to this minion and yeah a monster
although he's still got some of that
like minion appeal this would be like an
anime like a manga adaptation yeah
Despicable Me I think you can try to
emulate a particular style and you can
learn a lot from doing that yeah but at
the end of the day when you draw
something in your own style that
translation of it is something that's
totally about yeah that's totally you
having your own style and you know as
you draw and as you learn that style
will come to you that's for all you
young artists out there trying to find
yourself I believe in you
draw more Naruto these
what Jackie's
[Music]
[Music]